- [Gary] And ultimately, and finally
buy the New York jets.
Win six super bowls, and then die.
(intro music)
You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
So, some people are coming through.
I had a really fun day on vacation
where I was selling
baseball cards on Twitter
and the kicker was like,
you can come and pick it up
so, obviously people were buying it
just cause that.
It was really fun to meet that kid.
- [Kid] When I took college,
I had such a bad mind set.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Because I was like,
"I don't really wanna be here.
I just wanna work."
- Yeah.
- But, listening to the podcast everyday,
having positivity in my ears
has really just like, helped me along.
- Really thought it was an opportunity to
kinda create some clarity here.
I think what's really tough
about putting out content
on the internet for all us
creators and content producers is
some people just consume
one video, or one time
or you've got a subtle
message that even yourself
you're not doing a great
job of communicating on and
that's what I'm kinda trying to do here.
I put so much pressure
on college, my thesis
I'm like, "It's shit,
it's shit, it's shit."
And so much so that I think the subtleties
of my biggest macro, which is like,
look of the bright side,
glass is half full.
Make the best of your situation
and no matter what the situation is
is far greater than my
concern that collecting debt
in college is not setting you up
for financial success post college.
You know, for example you could be
collecting debt like that young man is and
I don't know.
We didn't get to that as
you can see in the video,
but, let's say he is.
Him going into college
over the next three and a half years
with a positive mind set may
lead to him meeting somebody
who becomes their ...
You know like, it's offense.
He meets somebody.
He meets Seth.
Seth becomes friends with him.
Seth gets into Vayner.
Seth then gets him into Vayner.
Seth's the ...
People don't get it.
When you're positive, when you're happy
it's not fluffy bull shit.
It's not like, "Oh, you're
drinking the Kool-aid."
It's being practical to understand that
yes always beats no,
that sun always beats rain,
that positivity always beats anger,
and people get confused cause
anger and negative and
doing the wrong thing
actually has short term results.
If me, Seth and Caleb go rob
a jewelry store tonight and
don't get caught, we got a
bunch of fucking jewelry,
but it now becomes the vulnerability
cause the second time, we may get caught
because I promise you, you don't rob
a jewelry store just once.
If you understood what I just said,
you're on your way.
I love when people, you know,
like to me it's just the truth.
To me, I don't think I'm
nice, or a prick or anything.
I think it's really a
good idea about talk ...
If you talk about the truth
it puts you in a position of strength.
As you know, now hearing your story,
the advantages, and they're substantial,
the advantages that you and I had is that
immigrant families have such
context for all the opportunity
so, it's hard for them to complain
about dumb shit.
- [Interviewer] There is no complaining.
- [Gary] Americans born here to abundance
complain about dumb shit, and by the way,
I'm not like, "You fucking idiots."
- No, No absolutely not.
- I'm like, "That's your
situation. You didn't know."
- Right.
- You didn't know.
- I always say, if you're
born in this country,
you got a social security number,
you can aspire to the
top of that building.
There shouldn't be any issues.
I look at people and I'm like,
I know people who aren't here other ways
and they're aspiring as well.
- But, here's where you and I won,
people born in this country
have lots of money in the bank
but have parents that
don't create the blueprint
that leads them to success here.
- Yeah, you've mentioned
it. It's the legacy.
- Dude, it's this.
- Yeah, the mindset.
- It's a mindset game.
It's the operating system.
People understand,
like, if your operating system
on your phone is fucked,
this is garbage,
but they don't understand
when this is fucked ....
- It fucks everything up.
- [Gary] I just think, yes, is powerful.
- [Scott] Yeah, well listen,
like what they say in improv,
never say no. Always say
yes and roll with it.
- And to me, the no players
are friends who are like,
"Focus. Focus. Focus."
They're like, "Look. Look how
successful I was. I focused."
I'm like,
"Cool. I said yes, and was
helter skelter. I'm successful."
I think a lot of this comes
down to self awareness.
I think when you can
accept yourself, you know
and for me, you said a very
subtle thing in there that
once you learn that you have
to accept it as a net game,
that those ...
For every meeting that led to
amazing things with Pinterest
there was six others that led to nothing
- Absolutely.
- Or a waste of time
or an awkward situation,
or things that you didn't wanna deal with.
It's a part of the game.
A lot of my mistakes helped
me get better at the no's
in a world where I wanna
say yes to everything.
- Hi.
You guys ready?
Why we are here is very simple.
Nine years ago, my brother and
I wanted to start a company.
The opportunity we saw at hand was
in the advertising agency world, but
it was to be a gateway to
everything else we ever did.
Somewhere in my late
twenties, early thirties,
I realized that even though
I suck at most things,
my ability to understand human beings and
communicate to them was strong,
and intuitively I understood
what humans were gonna do
often times before the masses.
It's why I invested in things
that went on to become big things.
It's why in 1996, I launched an eCommerce
wine business to sell wine.
Everything good in my life,
marrying my wife one second
into our first conversation,
everything good in my life has
been predicated on my ability
to understand human behaviors
slightly before the rest.
That was the mission of VaynerX.
That continues to be
the mission of VaynerX.
That will forever be
How do we build something
that communicates
to solve a problem at scale,
whether that is to sell sneakers,
or wine, or beer, or
telco, or whatever it is
or, as I get older in my years
to get Hussein to be the
governor of California
or to cure Crohn's
disease, or anything else.
Ultimately, and finally,
buy the New York Jets,
win six super bowls
and then die.
- This is where we're going so,
I'm excited. Thank you.
Thank you for your attention.
(applause)
- [Elliot] How's it going?
- [Gary] Really good.
- My name's Elliot.
- Elliot.
- I just wanted to personally tell you,
thank you so much for the opportunity
to work with your company.
I've been watching you and your company
for a very long time.
I come from a single mom household
from East Orange, New
Jersey to Newark, it's hard.
- Yeah, it is.
- It's really hard to even have somebody.
I've come from a corporate
background so, you know
just being there, I really
appreciate the environment
and the culture of this company.
- I appreciate that.
- I just wanted to personally thank you.
- Thank you so much.
- I appreciate you, man.
- Hey, I'm looking forward to
getting to know you better.
- Hey, absolutely.
- Hit me up any time.
Thank you for saying that.
- I'm a studio resident,
so I'm here till November
I hope I have the opportunity
to be here for a time.
- You make sure you email me
before that ends. I'm dead serious.
- Thank you.
- You got it.
(outro music)